اسمع بس صوته صوته مره واحده واحده مش ع
نفسي اسمع صوته مره واحده بس يعني عن جد
انا طفله فلسطينيه انا احرم من بابا ليش
طول الحرب لحت الان ما شفتش وجه ل بابا من
سعت ما اخذوه وانا بعيط بعيط انا مش قادره
اتحمل طول الليل بقى ضعيف بسح يا ماما
بلاقيها
بتعيط بقول لها مالك ياما بتعيطي بتقول لي
بعيط عشانكم ست كمان الله يعينها الثانيه
بتضلها تعيط بالليل وامي عن جد يعني احنا
مش عارفين كيف نصرف علينا كيف نجيب له اق
مث الاكل امي لما تجيب لنا الاكل ب بطعمي
اياه وهي ما بترضى تاكل بالمره ليش عشان
يحاول انه الاكل يكفينا احنا لقمه عيش
يعني نحاول انه نصبر حالنا لما ن تجيبلنا
نتفه رز ما بترضاش تاكل بس مطعمنا ايا
احنا بحكيلها كل يما معانا بترضاش ليش
عشان يكفينا الاكل عن جد يعني احنا كلنا
ست انصار ومع ماما وبابا ثمانيه وكلنا نا
احساء سته وعمامه كلهم كلهم لسار هدول
معددين من عائلات كثيره يعني انا
تعبت
ه